en el vídeo anterior sobre la
replicación del adn
vimos con algo de detalle la cadena
adelantada la cadena rezagada y todos
los diferentes actores enzimáticos que
participan en este proceso pero deje de
lado lo que es probablemente el aspecto
más alucinante de todo esto y esa es la
velocidad y la precisión con la que esto
está sucediendo como lo vimos en el
vídeo anterior este es un proceso
bastante complejo
tenemos la topoisomerasa que esta vez
enrollando las cadenas de adn la el y
casa que separan estas cadenas la
polimerasa que solo puede ir en
dirección 5 prima a 3 prima y que
necesita de un cebador para empezar a
añadir los nucleótidos en la cadena
rezagada también se necesita el cebador
de arn para poder ir en dirección 5
prima a 3 prima de manera que se van
formando estos fragmentos de okazaki y
toda esta locura que está pasando y
recuerda estas cosas no tienen un
cerebro y no son computadoras no saben
exactamente a dónde ir
todo esto ocurre debido a la química
todos estos actores deben de chocar
entre sí de la manera correcta y
reaccionar para que suceda todo este
proceso increíble y lo que estoy a punto
de decirte realmente va a dejarte
totalmente impresionado ya que esto está
sucediendo de manera increíblemente
rápida ha sido registrado que la adn
polimerasa al menos en la bacteria
e.coli se ha registrado añadiendo
aproximadamente 1000 pares de bases por
segundo creo que el número que vi fue de
700 y tantos pares de bases por segundo
así que déjame escribir esto vale la
pena anotarlo porque es algo totalmente
alucinante te da una noción de lo
increíble que es la maquinaria en tus
células así que ha llegado a esta
velocidad puede cambiar se ha observado
que se puede acelerar y ralentizar pero
la polimerasa
alcanza
más de 700
pares de bases x
segundo
así que en este diagrama esto está
sucediendo super rápido al menos desde
nuestro marco de referencia perceptual
para nosotros un segundo puede parecer
un lapso de tiempo muy corto pero en una
escala molecular estas cosas se
encuentran chocando unas contra otras y
llevando a cabo todo este proceso
ahora la segunda cosa que puede que te
estés preguntando es bien esto está
pasando muy rápidamente pero seguramente
debido a eso tiene una gran cantidad de
errores bueno lo primero que podemos
pensar es si tuviera una gran cantidad
de errores en realidad eso no sería
bueno para la biología porque siempre se
ha hecho la replicación del adn ocurre a
lo largo de nuestras vidas y si fuera
así llegaría un momento en el que
hubiera tantos errores acumulados que
las células no podrían funcionar y así
por suerte para nosotros este es un
proceso bastante preciso incluso en la
primera pasada de la polimerasa hay
un error
por cada
aproximadamente
10 a la séptima potencia así que estos
son 10 millones de nucleótidos
y creativos
y esto podría parecer bastante preciso
pero recuerda que tenemos miles de
millones de nucleótidos en nuestro adn
así que esto seguiría introduciendo una
gran cantidad de errores pero hay una
revisión de errores que se asegura de
que esos errores no permanezcan ahí y
así una vez que esta revisión se lleva a
cabo
tenemos un error
por cada aproximadamente 10 a la 9
nucleótidos
así que esto sucede a una velocidad
increíblemente rápida tan rápida como
más de 700 pares de bases por segundo
acercándose a mil pares de bases por
segundo y hay un error por cada 1000
millones de nucleótidos especialmente
después de pasar por este paso la
revisión de errores así que es un
proceso increíblemente rápido y es
increíblemente preciso así que espero
que esto te dé una mejor apreciación de
lo mágico que es esto ya que
literalmente esto estaba ocurriendo
ahora mismo en la mayoría de las células
de tu cuerpo